what's good people rich role here your
friendly podcast host going full
revenant with the sequestration beard
welcome I hope this greets you with
health and well-being as we navigate
this precarious moment together on the
subject of piloting the pandemic my
guest today is dr. David Katz David is a
graduate of Dartmouth the Albert
Einstein College of Medicine and Yale
School of Public Health he is also the
founding director of Yale University's
Yale Gryphon Prevention Research Center
he's a former professor at Yale School
of Medicine a past president of the
American College of lifestyle medicine
and the founder and president of the
true Health Initiative recent events
have found David on the forefront as
this prominent voice and how we as a
society should be thinking about and
responding to the coronavirus epidemic
so today we're gonna explore just that
in a conversation I think you're gonna
find both compelling and instructive
technical note this was my first attempt
at recording a zoom call for video I
forgot to hit record on that zoom call
until we are about two or three minutes
into our conversation so you're gonna
have to bear with us for the first
couple minutes you're gonna see the
camera on me and not on him but then
everything normalizes the production
value was great and I think you guys are
going to enjoy it so without further ado
hit that subscribe button leave your
comments below and without I give you
dr. David Katz
[Music]
well nice to see you David welcome to
the podcast
this is a long time coming we have a bit
of history we've actually never met in
person but we've gone back and forth
over the years and I feel very connected
to you I've wanted you to come on the
show for many years I think we've had
some back-and-forth and I could never
make it up to Connecticut to make that
happen and I always imagined that our
podcast would all would be all about
nutrition and lifestyle but here we are
in a moment in which I'm seeking your
wisdom and experience in and all
altogether different matter specifically
how we should be thinking about and
responding individually and as a society
to this kovat 19 pandemic but before we
launch into that perhaps you could
provide us with a little bit of
background on your work you've been a
prominent voice in lifestyle medicine
for many years but the pandemic has
really placed you in the public
spotlight in a very unique and different
way so I'm interested in how this has
come to pass and how we've arrived at
this moment so am I asking every day
rich what is going on yeah yeah well
first of all thanks for the intro I feel
the same way I feel like we've known one
another for years and it's always on
when when your work is so overlapping
and your ambitions are so aligned to
discover absolutely we haven't met in
person that yeah we right it's just at
some point it just becomes that can't be
true yeah I guess it's true that's weird
so it's great to join you and and I
would argue actually that what we've
always wanted to talk about diet
lifestyle is medicine the value
proposition there how much good could be
done by getting that formula right and
what we need to talk about in this
moment with everybody fixated on Co but
actually overlapped tremendously and I
actually think rich that's why I'm where
I
and you know I I didn't choose a career
focused on nutrition and lifestyle
because I like food more than other
people right I chose it because that's
where the action was you know as I in
the early going of my Chris I trained in
internal medicine and you know during
110 hours a week in the hospital for
several years it was painfully clear to
me that 8 out of 10 people in hospital
beds never needed to get that sick in
the first place and we were all the
king's horses and all the king's men you
know the best we were ever going to be
able to do is sort of hash them up but
never make them whole never make them
vital never unscramble the eggs and and
so I went on to trained in preventive
medicine to address that part and then I
chose to focus on nutrition and
lifestyle because it was becoming clear
at the time that diet in America was a
leading determinant of health outcomes
vitality longevity years in life and
years that's why I chose it and in fact
what we've realized in the year since is
diet is number one single leading
predictor variable for all cause
mortality in the United States there was
an op-ed in the New York Times August
26th of 2019 by Dairy schmoes offeri and
at Tufts and Dan Glickman former
Secretary of Agriculture our food is
killing too many of us and that's the
argument they make number one predictor
variable so that's what I do you know I
kind of want to be where stuff's on fire
and bring a bucket and try to help put
it out and it's the very same
inclination that got me caught up in the
köppen response I was looking at the
data from all around the world in the
very early going so out of Wuhan and out
of South Korea and people were starting
to freak out over here we weren't yet
sure what was gonna happen in the United
States and you know some people were
dismissing it I thought that was wrong
some people were getting hysterical I
thought that was wrong I said you know
it looks to me like essentially this is
two very different diseases there's a
relatively small portion of the
population very elderly people and
people with serious chronic illness for
whom this is a really bad
actor and then there's a large segment
of the population 98 to 99 percent of
everybody who gets this thing who may
not even know they've had it and you
know South Korea has consistently
reported out of more than ten thousand
cases they detected ninety-eight percent
were relatively mild something close to
that high 90s anyway and and the real
burden of this so the likelihood of
hospitalization ICU or death was
massively concentrated among people who
were elderly and/or chronically ill same
thing in Italy actually you know we were
all fixated on that terrible mortality
toll in northern Italy but I think it
was only 2.1 percent of all the deaths
occurred in people under age 70 and 1.2
percent of all the deaths occurred in
people who were free of some major
chronic disease most of the mortality
toll was in older people with chronic
disease so I was looking at that and I
said you know we're talking about
shutting down society we're talking
about you know closing down businesses
and as a public health person I've
always been very respectful of the
social determinants of health poverty is
a major determinant of health outcomes
food insecurity desperation destitution
so I wrote an op-ed which the New York
Times wound up publishing they called it
you know it is the cure worse than the
disease I had called it something
differently I was I was arguing
basically for a more surgical strike
look this is not an equal opportunity
scourge some people are high-risk summer
at low risk we should do different
things for those two population groups
but it wound up being called is the Cure
worse than disease and and really the
issue was this this pandemic can hurt
people at least two different ways it
can hurt them by infecting them and it
can hurt them if our interdiction
methods ruin livelihoods and lives and
both of those are bad what we ought to
be striving for is total harm
minimization where we minimize the harm
of the infection and minimize the harm
of the interdiction and that led me in
the direction of what I call vertical or
risk
interdiction let's protect the people
who most need protection let's not shut
down more than we need to shut down
I wrote my op-ed and then Tom Friedman a
three-time Pulitzer Prize winner
long-standing columnist at the New York
Times called me on a Saturday night
everything literally out of the blue my
phone rings it's a number from Bethesda
I don't recognize and I usually don't
answer those calls but I said you know I
just had a piece in the New York Times
who knows what this is about let me
check it it's Tom Friedman and I mean I
ran around the house basically saying
and forgive me for speaking blood holy
[ __ ] you won't believe who called me you
know Tom Friedman just called me out of
the blue so Tom said you know I really
liked that this perspective and he
wanted to build his column around it
which he did and let's just say the rest
is history so no Tom channeled my
thinking in a column he wrote which ran
it up a really high flagpole and then
all hell broke loose you know I got
calls from the governor of New York and
the governor of Florida legislators and
testifying to the Senate and all the
media appearances and so forth and is it
valid yes you asked me about my
background so just briefly I'm
board-certified in preventive medicine
public health formally trained in
epidemiology have co-authored multiple
editions of a leading textbook on
epidemiology preventive medicine public
health and biostatistics taught all of
those courses at the Yale School of
Medicine for well over a decade so you
know ordinarily I focus on diet
lifestyle because that's most important
but the training really is preventing
disease promoting health patterns and
populations epidemiology and an
understanding not just of infectious
disease epidemiology because I would
defer to others there who know more than
I do I'm not a religious certainly but I
also know a lot about social
determinants and how you know the way
this reverberates through all aspects of
society translates into public health
matters of great importance so I'm
seeing the big picture and opining and
here we are right so this op-ed piece is
published March
xx I believe right and and if memory
serves me there was a sort of ten day
gestation period from the date in which
you originally wrote this up until the
date that it was actually published
correct so exactly I suspect you're
writing this in the wake of hearing that
the NBA has suspended its its season and
Tom and Rita Hanks have contracted the
disease this is you know at the very
beginning stages of trying to grapple
with how to deal with all of this also
in a period in which every single day
feels like a year in terms of how much
change there is clearly we've adopted
what you would call a horizontal
interdiction approach to all of this and
your piece was really about adopting a
more surgical approach and so where are
we you know now here we are May 5th
a lot has changed has this has the
evolution of our approach and what
you're sort of canvassing and seeing
right now change your perspective in
that original op-ed piece which we
should also mention has become a little
bit of a political flashpoint right yeah
as everything I mean our society so
polarized it doesn't really matter how
moderate or centrist your point of view
is it gets distorted in both directions
so you know it's never liberal enough
for people you know it's being left it's
never conservative enough for people in
the extreme right I mean no matter what
you're you're you're a human pinata but
yeah just as you say rich so I actually
wrote it originally ten days before it
ran in the New York Times and at that
time the early stuff was happening you
know we heard about Tom Hanks and and
his wife and all of that but we had not
yet made the fateful decision to close
down all of the universities in the
country and send those kids home and I
have five adult children and three of
them were in that population at
demographic and I was thinking hmm you
know what we're seeing in South Korea
and increasingly in other countries is
that you know young healthy people may
have this in
not even know what if that's going on in
the college campuses so you know
potentially I'm gonna take a lot of
young people seemingly perfectly healthy
who have asymptomatic versions of of
Kovac we're gonna send them home to
their 50 something parents who if their
typical Americans have you know at least
one major chronic disease at least
hypertension or type 2 diabetes or car
nerd disease and in a multi-generational
home they may have their 70 something
grandparents living there too it really
looks like it's potentially a bad
disease and the parents it looks like
it's a devastating disease for the
grandparents maybe these kids are better
off staying in college campuses and
let's just you know kind of wait and see
what happens because you know maybe they
all get over it develop immunity to it
and you know that's when we send them
home we didn't do that those were the
thoughts I was having between the time I
originally wrote this in the time it ran
the gauntlet to get published in the New
York Times we sent the kids home we shut
down businesses in New York City I had
three of my own kids come back home to
shelter in place here but okay you know
that the die is cast ali-a octa asked
you know and I thought okay I you know I
it looks to me with the dithering and
delay your you know we're probably gonna
close the barn doors after letting all
the horses run loose and I kind of think
that's what we did and we're still
watching how that plays out um you know
in terms of my own perspective so I it
it's been informed obviously by the flow
of data ever since I first opened but it
was also very important to me not to sit
this out on the sidelines and so when
the call went out for volunteers in New
York City I immediately signed up it
took a while to work through the
bureaucracy but eventually I got
deployed in the Bronx and I did several
12-hour shifts in an emergency
department in the Bronx so I got to see
this up close and personal you know we
admitted case after case of kovat but
actually it reaffirmed my view so I saw
the young healthy people in the ER for
other reasons who oh by the way probably
had Cova - and they got sent home and
they were almost certainly gonna be fine
I saw the occasional person in the
Middle where you know as little dicey we
hope they get better they might get
worse most of the docs I was working
with had had it and recovered from it
some of them had been tested and had -
choir
t9 came back to work some of them did
this and said I'm pretty sure I had it I
didn't tell anybody I just worked
straight through it on the other hand
there was a bulletin board in the
emergency room with a picture of a
beautiful woman with a lovely smile
rest in peace it was one of the nurses
who had contracted this and gotten
relatively young woman so you know again
the minute you stopped respecting this
disease it is going to kill somebody you
love and I never lost sight of that but
the patients that were most consistently
being admitted and that were destined to
the ICU or that died in the emergency
room before we could admit them or were
likely to die in the hospital were
mostly elderly sick people sent from the
nursing home and you know in the early
going of my career I worked for five
years part-time as an ER doc and it was
exactly the pattern I saw then there was
one major difference so you know you
always see ambulance after ambulance
from nursing homes
those are frail people on any given day
am i stroke urosepsis all these
different things that happen what was
different was same demographic more or
less the same volume but everybody had
the same diagnosis that's weird
everybody had called it so you know no
question it was different by the time I
was serving in New York it was already a
little too late my colleagues were
saying we really needed you a week ago
and I you know I said I signed up right
away took a while to get through the
system but my view actually remains the
same as it was that you know again New
York's done zero prevalence testing it
looks like 20% of the state may have had
this as four million people so you know
that the death toll in New York relative
to a denominator of four million is a
tiny fraction of a percent highly
concentrated in older chronically ill
people that pattern is being repeated
around the world the diamond princess
you know really a contained environment
only 20% of the people on the ship got
infected and by the way that's a pattern
we've seen repeated - I don't know what
it means rich but I'm wondering you know
80% of people natively resistant to just
to getting this infection that we
actually have data out of Germany out of
Sweden out of Iran the diamond princess
the navy ships and some evidence out of
California and the New York zero
prevalence
that suggests in a population that's
widely exposed to this 8 out of 10
people don't even get the infection and
of those who do get it most of them
either don't know it all have no
symptoms they have mild symptoms but on
the other hand I have I've looked the
enemy in the eye and it's a terrible
bizarre disease and I'm aware that it
has killed young health professionals
and so I always respected the potential
of this infection to hurt people but you
know with it with a total mortality toll
even this many months into it very close
to seasonal flu in the United States I
mean they're really right in the same
ballpark and 30 million people
unemployed because of our societal
response to this you know so that's 500
people who've lost their job for every
one person who has lost their life to
this both are bad so I continue to think
we should shift now to risk-based
interdiction we need to protect nursing
homes we need to identify as artfully as
we can all of those groups at elevated
risk of severe infection and I think we
ought to double down protecting them and
and this is what I hope some of our
discussion will be about today we all
sort of we need a national let's get
healthy now campaign there's never been
a better time to get people to care
about their weight and their insulin
resistance their diabetes their heart
disease because you know whereas those
who are slow motion threats before
everybody's acutely concerned about Kobe
Kobe has turned chronic health
liabilities into the kind of acute
threat that tickles your adrenal gland
and activates the fight-or-flight
response so we've got people's attention
so we should identify risk we should
modify risk we should protect people at
elevated risk but I really do think a
large segment of the population can
return to normalcy and and there's a
reason that's important rich if we don't
get this those of us who you know who
can safely get this infection get over
it and make antibodies to it we are
waiting for a vaccine to get our lives
back and that may be a very long time
away from now right I mean Ronna viruses
are tricky bugs it's been really hard to
make vaccines to them and you know 18
months has been the optimistic
mind if we hit snags it could be three
years it could be five years I mean it's
hard to imagine life like this for five
years if we're hoping to get back any of
what was here before right I think that
that irrespective of the importance of
flattening the curve and you point this
out in in the op-ed and it came up in
your in your segment with Bill Maher
flattening the curve doesn't obviate us
from contracting the disease it just
pushes a timeline out right so as some I
want it yeah I want to credit someone
for that actually so two colleagues and
and one of the beautiful things that
happened from my point of view wish
because you know I'm not an expert in
mathematical risk modeling I am NOT an
expert in biology but after I Tom
Friedman you know gave me the exposure
that his column gave me a who's who in
in all of these different fields social
determinants of health health economics
mathematical models found me on the one
hand it's been completely overwhelming
trying to keep up on the other it's been
an incredible privilege learning from
all these people
so Maria chiquinha at University of
Pittsburgh and West peg Ian at Carnegie
Mellon they're a couple that does
mathematical risk modeling and they
published a piece entitled something
along the lines a call for honesty in
pandemic modeling and they actually they
went into an online tool that had been
featured in a New York Times column by
Nick Kristof whom I loved but Nick was
talking about the importance of
flattening the curve and they showed how
you flatten the curve and you don't get
that huge spike in hospitalizations and
deaths and it's really important to
avoid overwhelming the medical system
Marija and West didn't create a new tool
they went into that very tool and said
okay if you look at what was published
in the New York Times it you know it
looks like there's a slight uptick right
where they cut off the curve we're going
to show you what happens if you release
the clamp and there was the same high
spike in hospitalizations and deaths
they said in other words if all if your
entire plan is flattening the curve you
have to do it forever
or until there is a highly effective
vaccine mass-produced and uniformly
administered because the minute you let
go everything you thought you were
preventing happens all you've done is
changed the days that that was that was
an aha moment for me I it had occurred
to me from the start that you know that
we could again pivot to risk based
interdiction I hadn't thought to say you
know this actually can be configured
directly into the risk model so that yes
you flatten the curve at first so you
don't overwhelm hospital systems that's
obviously important but you need
something to transition to unless you're
just gonna hunker in a bunker and wait
for a vaccine but that could be a very
long timeline and an awful lot of life
as we knew it before will be gone by the
time we all come out from under our
desks yeah I think that that risk
assessment ends up being motivated in
part by an emotional response to what
we're seeing because there seems to be a
great crevice between some of the data
that you cited and the the harrowing and
sobering accounts that you'll find if
you scroll through your Twitter feed
from ICU doctors or people that have
contracted the disease who paint you
know a very scary picture of what it's
like to endure this or to you know die
in an ICU unable to be surrounded by
your loved ones okay and and I think
that we should all take those stories to
heart and and certainly this is this is
not to you know minimize the severity of
what we're dealing with but I don't
think that it can get in the way of
driving an objective well-thought-out
plan for how we're going to you know
navigate and ultimately come out the
other side here and there is a
difference between complete horizontal
interdiction where we're on complete
lockdown and the other extreme of just
doing whatever you want everybody back
yeah and I suppose on some level Sweden
is the canary in the coal mine
here by taking a attack that is
somewhere you know in the middle of that
spectrum or perhaps you know bent to the
right in terms of allowing people to do
what they want and people have a lot of
opinions about that and are drawing
conclusions but my sense is that it's
way too early to assess the success or
failure of what Sweden is attempting to
do I don't I don't know that we can
really objectively evaluate that for
another 18 to 24 months because of
course they're gonna have higher
contraction rates and death rates at
this moment but what does it look like
when there's a second wave or a year
from now when we're trying to resume
life on some level of normalcy
I wish personally I hope we do sooner
than a year from now so yeah a number of
really good points let me start with
this one many years ago rich I wrote an
article in the american journal of
health promotion facing the facelessness
of public health as you know I'm a
physician at thirty years of clinical
care but my career really has been
focused on public health and it occurred
to me many years ago that public health
Labor's under a tremendous encumbrance
and that is nobody cries for the public
nobody hears statistics and and you know
and has a tear in their eye nobody feels
passion for the public but the public is
a fiction there is no public there's you
and me and everybody else and the
problem with much of what you and I do
all the time you know we talk about the
value proposition of lifestyle 80% of
all chronic disease could go away we
don't make people cry we don't make
people feel passion because 80% is a
bland statistic I've tried to fix that
in talks I've given by asking my
audiences how many of you love somebody
who's had a heart attack how many of you
love somebody who's had a stroke or
dementia or diabetes or cancer now
everybody who puts your hands in the air
you know try to remember the day you
found out about that diagnosis and how
you felt and now imagine a world where
eight times in ten we don't put our
hands up because that's what an 80%
reduction in chronic disease would feel
like it's not remote it's not anonymous
it's not about some entity
all the public that isn't about you or
me it's about you and me and our
families and people we love but it's a
huge burden to overcome and the way you
overcome it is storytelling you put a
face in the newspaper and say this is
what we mean now here's the problem the
the news media have fixated exclusively
on coab they've been feeding our anxiety
about kovat for weeks and weeks and
weeks and you could easily get the
impression that nobody in America dies
of anything else
the reality is heart disease kills 1,800
people a day in our country and has been
doing it forever 8,000 people die in the
United States every day of miscellaneous
causes so you could pick any one of
those causes you could pick just heart
disease you could pick just cancer you
could pick just traffic accidents and
say we're going to experiment well you
know all the different media outlets are
just going to tell stories about this
one condition all the time and we're
going to we're going to talk about the
epidemiology and the statistics and the
population level risk but we're also
going to tell the human interest stories
and you know honestly if we had done
that I think we would be much more
concerned about heart disease than we
seem to be and maybe would have done
something about it since it's all
preventable but we have done exactly
that with coalbed and so there are
actually two implications one yeah
you're right to care as much as you do
these are real people and and these are
you know these are grieving families and
it's all compounded by the fact that you
can't be together you know in those
moments of acute need and that's unique
and it's terrible but the other is
massive massive risk distortion you know
the feeling that you know because you
know you tell the story for example that
a child a seemingly healthy child dies
of kovat and every parent in the country
thinks well you know never sending my
kids back to school mm-hmm but the
reality is every year in this country
some number of kids die because parents
put them in the car to drive them to
school and that number is much bigger
than Kobe or they die because they're on
a school bus or they died because they
rode their bikes outside now these are
all tragedies but we're fixating only on
the one cause and it is distorting our
perception so yeah I totally agree with
you the human interest component
absolutely important but why is it
if the cause of death is something other
than Kovac those are real people - those
are real families - so we we need to
reconcile those two views we need to
respect this disease we need to care
enormous ly about every individual every
family that is suffering the anguish of
this but we also need to recognize
families were suffering loss in anguish
in the United States before Kovac
will be suffering after Kovac diet alone
poor diet the thing you and I devote all
our efforts to kills half a million
people five hundred thousand so thus far
almost ten times as many people as the
total death toll from Kovan that's today
but almost ten times as many every year
kills them prematurely right where's the
outrage where's the where's the passion
and the compassion about that we're not
telling those stories what if that was
in the newspaper every day another
person died of diseases related to diet
in America and yet another and another
and another and another you know we
could tell all of those stories with
with faces and families but we tend not
to so it's important it's valid it's
also a distortion yeah I suppose the
qualitative difference with perspective
a heart disease or diabetes example is
that you're not going to contract one of
those diseases by being in the proximity
of somebody that that has it but yes and
no yes and no I again it's valid and
there a number of important differences
I'm not gonna argue against that but the
the medium of transmission for kovat is
droplets through the air the medium of
transmission for death by diet is
culture but yes being in America place
you at risk being in this culture means
it's likely to be transmitted to you and
by the way if it's transmitted to you
it's likely to be transmitted to your
children and there's a pretty robust
literature on social networks and the
risk of obesity diabetes and heart
disease so you could argue all that's
really different is the timeline and the
mechanism of transmission but these are
transmissible conditions
and they play out over longer timelines
but they ultimately affect a lot more
people and you know you could say
because they happen slower maybe that
means kovetz worse but you know you
could also argue the other way well
here's the thing about those chronic
diseases they beat you up for a long
time before they kill you you know or
they ever take years from your life they
take a lot of life out of your years and
they're affecting children routinely
Nanako so yes again you know ballad we
create social norms around risk
assessment all the time I mean it would
it's certainly possible that we could
institute a federal law that says you
can't drive your car more than 10 miles
an hour we could make Auto travel say
more safe far more safe than it is
there's plenty of things that we could
do to minimize risk for Public Health
and Safety but there's this valence this
this spectrum that I think is calibrated
in accordance with Liberty and and and
personal freedoms so there's an I agree
with you at listen you're a terrific
interviewer really I mean just no
seriously I'm really enjoying this let
me point something out if I may risk it
it's a totally different topic but I
think it does shine a light on this we
had a huge societal hullabaloo about
legalizing medical marijuana let alone
recreational marijuana but just medical
marijuana was there was a lot of
controversy right mm-hmm but the public
didn't realize is that cocaine was legal
all along it's in every emergency room I
used it as an ER doc we use a seven
percent solution of cocaine on a cup on
a cotton swab and shove it up your nose
when you come in with bad epistaxis
basically hemorrhage from the nose
nothing works better to cauterize the
bleeding temporarily so we can look in
there and see what's going on and fix it
so cocaine was legal to say nothing of
drugs like dilaudid which is a much more
potent opioid than heroin and
benzodiazepines which are you know
really dangerous habit-forming go so in
other words drugs off-the-charts more
dangerous than marijuana were legal all
the time and since they were legal all
the time nobody even thought to question
it mm-hmm but the simple reason that
marijuana wasn't legal in the first
there was this intense consternation oh
my god a drug should it be available and
I would argue there's a bit of that
going on so yeah you can have much
greater risks to any segment of the
population including children that
nobody pays much attention to because
they are already normalized and even if
the risks associated with kovat were
much lower you still have a hard time
talking people into them because we had
already decided
Kovach risk is unacceptable and in some
sense it's a little bit like juxtaposing
medical marijuana and medical cocaine
there are greater risks that hide in
plain sight that we blindly accept
because we're used to them and simply
because this is new and exotic and we
decided it was unacceptable right at the
beginning it's going to be a hard time
even when we tell people yeah you know
the risk to your child going to school
in the era of kovat may be comparable to
the risk of driving your child to school
for three months it's still gonna be
difficult to talk people into that but I
do think that's gonna be part of the
transition back right so here we are
where we're in around week eight I
believe of this experiment I know right
I can't I don't even remember what I was
like before and now when I watch a movie
and I see people hugging I'm visceral
reaction to it's very strange
but we've been pursuing this this path
for a while now do you think it's
possible at this point to shift courses
and and adopt a more strategic vertical
interdiction approach or has the dye
been cast and this is what we're living
with and we just have to you know
continue to pursue this way of life like
how are you thinking about our current
moment and if we could pivot setting
aside politics you know what would that
look like yeah I definitely think we can
I almost think it's inevitable that we
will because you know we're seeing these
tensions and
sadly you know as you point out I mean
it to me it's really quite surprising
that anything I said was very
controversial my objective clearly
stated from the very beginning was total
harm minimization and and by the way for
listeners we've collated all of our
materials on the website of the true
Health Initiative under that rubric
total harm minimization we have the risk
models and the the columns and the
essays and the blogs and the articles
but that was the goal we you know
basically said this this virus can kill
people unemployment food insecurity
hunger desperation domestic violence
suicide addiction that can kill people
too all of that's bad we need to be
looking across the full expanse of that
and devising policies to minimize total
harm so sort of surprising that what's
the controversy really and then you
you'd have to quickly append to that
well you know our efforts at minimizing
total harm can only be as good as our
data we need to harms our and who's
vulnerable to what and if we're going to
protect people we need to know where to
direct those efforts but what we're
seeing instead of you know a lot of
activity and what I think is the
sensible middle we're seeing the
polarization that we have sown in our
society so reaping what we've sown and
so you've got you know the we need to
keep everybody hunkering in their bunker
until there's a vaccine camp and you've
got everybody you know back in the water
now don't worry about grandma she'll be
fine never mind the riptides and the
sharks you know i reject both of those
and you could you could argue the better
way to find the middle path would
actually be to all come together link
arms and and you know lock little paths
but those opposing tensions are going to
achieve the same thing you know so
essentially each side is pushing back
against the other and you know the only
way out of the impasse is to say okay so
you know we've got to return to some
degree of normalcy and and yet we still
have to protect people and that that
would be vertical interdiction so I
think inevitably that's going to happen
what do we need to make that happen so
we actually do it well we need data
and at the time we're having this
conversation I'm about to testify to the
Senate Committee on Homeland Security I
mean really my world is such a one-way
mode right yeah that's what I said when
these guys called me seriously but
that's happening and I'm gonna say look
you know we've sort of bogged down in
this issue we need millions of tests and
we don't have the resources for millions
of tests so therefore we throw our hands
in the air not absolutely not
CDC routinely tells us really big stuff
like you know dive quality in America
and trends and dietary intake and trends
and chronic disease not by testing
everybody in the country but doing
surveys like the BRFSS behavioral risk
factor surveillance system in
representative random samples we need a
representative random sample give me you
know 20,000 people 30,000 people we can
extrapolate to a population of 325
million we really can you just need to
make sure we've got urban suburban rural
all age groups all zip codes socio
economics different health status but
that's what we're talking about so you
really mean to tell me and and you know
better than 20,000 would be 50,000 but
it's a small number you can't tell me
the United States of America couldn't
pull together the wherewithal to do a
representative random sample where we
know whether you're infected or not
whether you're immune or not your health
status and all the rest it's the work of
72 hours it really is so I would argue
we can do better than Sweden you know
Sweden basically guessed and Sweden
could have done better protecting their
nursing homes frankly Sweden certainly
didn't have the data they needed to know
who in the general population is in the
high-risk group but you know I think we
can have Swedish cake and eat it too and
what I mean is let's get the data we
need so we really can risk stratify and
then say okay you know we've got
quintiles of risk or turtles of risk or
whatever it is I don't know whether it's
two groups three groups five groups
seven groups that you know were highly
differentiated but you know that the
highest risk groups fully protected
until we get to an all clear and the all
clear could be a vaccine but it could be
herd immunity achieved natively with
exposure to the virus to the lowest risk
group for whom the risk
severe covent infection is no greater
than seasonal flu and maybe lower
absolutely back out into the world back
to work back to school intermediate
groups intermittent intermediate
policies
so either phased back in after levels of
viral transmission or lower or back but
with personal protective equipment and
you know frankly if we do this
data-driven risk stratification I think
we could do a better job of taking care
of the people who need it most
my parents are 80 they had generally
healthy my mom's had some health issues
you know we've not hugged them since the
start of this you know they're
sheltering at their home my mother is
and I told the story in the media but
it's true you know she can't get through
a conversation about without crying
yeah okay yes I don't want to get coded
and die but I'm equally afraid of dying
of something else while waiting to be
able to hug my grandchildren again you
know I mean they're they're sort of
comparably terrible existential threats
when you're 80 years old and you know
that you're looking at the horizon of
you know your life coming to an end so
you know how does my mom get to her
grandchildren that's either a vaccine
and we don't know what that timeline is
or it's enough of us have had this
gotten over it that you know we can no
longer transmit it and we say mom it's
okay to come back to the world now so
you know we need to think about several
components we need to think about
minimizing total harm we need to think
about risk ears but we also need to
think how these things are configured
into some version of an all-clear
because you know you and I rich can talk
about this going on for a year or two or
three and it you know it's terrible but
we at least expect to still be here when
it ends right if you're 80 years old
this is not the way you want your life
to close out I mean that's just that's
truly horrible so that you know that
there's a whole cohort that's wondering
do I ever get back to the world before I
check out and and I want to fix that you
know that that's also part of the human
interest story here yeah I think that we
struggle entron on the subjective of
minimizing total harm
sort of grasping what that means and
what the approach is when we're dealing
with poverty isolation education food
insecurity but they they're abstractions
when we're dealing with the you know
very real and immediate threat of trying
to prevent people from contracting a
potentially fatal disease and so they
they get back Bernhard as something to
deal with later meanwhile I yeah but
that's why those stories need to be told
- right so you know again they are
abstractions unless you put a face to
and you start telling in your newspapers
and on television those human interest
stories you know we have we have the
option of telling the tale kovat fall
out more completely but my mom is not an
abstraction to me you know that
obviously and and you know so I'm
looking into the the weepy eyes of
someone who's saying I
you know I'm desperate to know that
there's a plan I'm desperate to know
that there's a path back to a world
where I get to hug my grandchildren and
I eat right and there is a sense that
that maybe there really isn't a plan
right now I mean we hear the the the
mantra of testing testing testing and
yet this world of testing seems to be
rife with all manner of problems when we
think about the antibody test or the
swab test there's a high degree of false
negatives as far as I've been told I
have a friend who first tested positive
then tested negative then tested
positive then tested negative again he's
pretty sure he had it but then it you
know then maybe he didn't and that foam
ents a lot of confusion and fear so when
you're talking about establishing a
cohort that you can then test and then
extrapolate the data from you know where
are we in terms of testing testing
accessibility and also testing veracity
ya know it's a really good point and I
can tell you that
whatever reason the third ignite three
12-hour shifts in the emergency room the
boss we admitted that day 20 people with
Kovac mm-hmm
I forget whether it was 19 or 20 who
tested negative with the nasal swabs
right I mean there was no doubt they had
it you know there's there there's now
sort of a classic lab panel their liver
function abnormalities kidney function
abnormalities coagulation abnormalities
there's there's a classic panel and it
just jumps off the page and screams : at
you and they all had that but their swab
was negative and so you know we knew for
sure that it was a bad batch of swabs or
what yeah so we need test kits we can
trust and with all the different
entities producing kits and competing
for their kiss to be used you know again
it's the work of a couple days to say
okay the most reliable test methods for
infection are and for antibodies are and
perfect yeah but perfect the enemy of
good we need good data good will do so
you know that needs to be done it should
be coordinated federally you know we
should have the FDA the CDC Department
of Health and Human Services
collaborating to get that sorted out the
best available kit should be deployed
and yeah we have the resources to do
50,000 tests we absolutely do we can't
do five million we certainly can't in 50
million but we can do 50 thousand and
that's what we ought to do but you're
right we need data we can trust but it's
interesting because as you say it's the
false negative error rate that appears
to be high and yet with all of the
population samples what we're finding is
a lot more people have had this thing
than we knew about so again in New York
it looks like twenty percent so that's
20 percent of the level of state that's
four million people and that translates
the mortality toll in the hardest-hit
part of the hardest-hit country to a
very small fraction of a percent now
that doesn't make this any less tragic
if you were one of those people or one
of those people was a loved one and and
you know I hasten to note that every
time we're talking about real people
real families real pain real loss but
what it does change is the likelihood
that you have been get this and I you
know if if out of all the people who get
this
uh you know 0.2% 4.1%
died of it then you know the likelihood
of you dying of it even if you get it is
that you know something like 0.1 or 0.2
percent less you're in a very high-risk
group in other words 99.9 percent
probable that if you get this you'll
recover from it mm-hmm and if and you
know if you're in a low-risk group its
99.999 you know that sort of thing so it
does absolutely change the the emotional
reaction to all of this so it's really
important so we need those data we need
those data so we know what to do we need
those data so we know who to protect we
need those data so individuals can make
some judgment about their personal risk
and process their fear I'm actually
working with colleagues on a personal
risk calculator which I you know III
used it myself and while this is great
I'm 57 years old I can tell you that
before I you know went off to work in a
New York City emergency department I had
to overcome a lot of resistance in my
family my kids freaked out my wife
freaked out my mother totally freaked
out you know there was crying and and
you know it made it hard for me and they
said you know you're doing so much to
address the policy just you know keep
doing that you don't need to be on the
frontlines you're making your
contribution see I just doesn't feel
right I'm a clinician I'm an internist I
have the skill set they need the help
how can I justify abdicating but there
you know there was a great deal of
anguish so you know 57 I'm and the
margin right 60 and above you're
definitely at high risk but I'm
extremely healthy I practice what we
preach and you know I'm a beneficiary of
it so I put myself through this risk
calculator that colleagues are working
on and it determined that my co vid risk
age was 40 17 years younger you know
which drops me you know so I have the
kovat related risk of a healthy 40 year
old right which meant you know my risk
of needing hospitalization if I get
infected is you know as a percent my
risk of the ICU is a fraction of percent
and my risk of dying of this is a tiny
fraction of a percent
and you know I think that's a it's a
useful reality check now those models
are only as good as the data flowing
into them and when we generate better
data the models will get better but even
so you know I think I think
qualitatively that's right my risk is
comparable to a person much younger
because of my health status and I can
look at that and say ok you know I feel
pretty good about this I mean it's very
unlikely that this disease is going to
hurt me so I can get out there on the
frontlines and help other people and you
know that reassured my family and you
were doing that in the Bronx correct
Rose was that at Robert Oz Feltes
Hospital Montefiore oh joy it's at Rob
ah spells hospital system so it was
monster fewer ok rob was in one of the
other hospitals so I didn't get to see
Rob during this time I was on the
Wakefield campus yeah so actually the
way this worked interesting story in its
own right New York City Health and
Hospitals corporation sent out a call
for volunteers I signed up and you know
I heard about this through Governor
Cuomo and then I got an email as an alum
of the Albert Einstein College of
Medicine which is home to the Montefiore
Medical Systems that's where I went to
medical school they sent out an email to
all of the alums and said we need help
so I signed up there too I immediately
heard back from New York City Health and
Hospitals you've been assigned to a
hospital in Brooklyn but here are the
multiple steps you need to go through to
clear our bureaucracy and it was hours
hours and hours of online trainings and
we had quizzes and so I said ok you know
I'm up to my eyeballs in work but I'll
do this as quickly as I can I started
working through it and and it took me
over a week to fit in all of those hours
of training much of it by the way about
stuff that was totally irrelevant like
billing Medicare fraud I was a volunteer
nobody was paying me anything but I had
to go through a training module about
Medicare fraud by the time I was
nine-tenths done with the onboarding for
New York City Health and Hospitals
Einstein got back inside oh no no we're
not doing any of that nonsense we can
assign you tomorrow I said ok so I you
know I basically wrote back to the folks
at the mothership you know for the state
and said give my assignment in Brooklyn
to somebody else I'm going to the Bronx
instead because they can deploy me
immediately and I have
made it through your garage bureaucracy
that's unfortunate because he having a
lot of people were caught up in that log
jam and wanted to be on the front lines
and we're trying to get through and by
the time all of us finally broke through
you know I think we were a little late
for the party
but in any event I wound up going to an
Einstein system and Monti is part of
Einstein so I so Rob and I were you know
we were basically in the same medical
system but at different campuses we hear
a lot about ventilators and you know
we're getting these stories from the
doctors on the front lines through
social media but what is you know how
would you relate that experience of
being in that environment and treating
people firsthand like what do people not
fully understand about that experience
and what that's like and and you know
where are some of the perhaps
misinformation all right let me address
that but before I do since we were just
talking about our friend Rob Oz Feld and
I just want to give a shout out to the
people who are there all the time you
know I I'm I retired from clinical care
after 30 years few years ago to focus on
public health these other things I do
and I went and helped but let's be clear
you know I just chipped in a little you
know Rob's been there from the beginning
and will be there through the end and
you know my colleagues who are
clinicians full-time you know the it's
day after day after day and you and I
have been saying on on during this
discussion rich that every day feels
like a month well I can tell you that 12
hours in an emergency department you
know with colvett case after Coby case
it felt like a year and these guys know
Rob and all of our clinical colleagues
they're doing this day after day after
day so I just can't say enough about the
support they deserve and and how hard
this is and I can tell you this you try
you know we made a big fuss about not
having PPE and not having n95 masks
there's no walk in the park to have one
either you try wearing an n95 mask for
12 hours straight
your nose is abraded at the end of the
day your head is hurting from the
elastic seriously I now couldn't believe
how eager I was to get the damn thing
wrong with 12 hours
girlfriend Danielle Bilardo has been
sharing voluminously this and related
subjects I mean she really you know I'm
Mike I don't know how she has time to
post everything that she's posting given
you know the circumstances that she
finds herself in but you know following
her gave me a very you know profound
kind of tactile connection to yeah good
for visceral experience of what that
must be like yeah yeah so I was I was
really glad to try it on but I can't say
I'm sorry that you know my contribution
was the equivalent of about one week of
work and you know doing it week after
week after week Wow you know it's it's
heavy load so so kudos to them and thank
you and I don't want more credit than I
deserve right you know my thinking was I
cannot abdicate they need help I'm gonna
sign up but my hope is you know ten
thousand people like me sign up too
because you know I'm gonna contribute a
week that doesn't make much difference
ten thousand weeks of work makes a huge
difference and so I should be part of it
overnight and I think I was anyway back
to ventilators so fascinating I have
never seen clinical medicine involved
this rapidly in a 30-year clinical
career I've never seen anything that
caused us to change fundamental norms of
treatment as fast as Koba did my
colleagues in the ER were telling me
last week this time we would have
intubated all these patients they would
have gone on ventilators and this week
we're not because this is a different
disease what's been described for kovat
is that its effect on the lung is a bit
like altitude sickness that the pressure
from the ventilator actually takes
uninjured parts of the lung and injures
them and causes them to undergo the
viral related damage which is very
different from typical pneumonia either
bacterial or viral and what's been
discovered along with many other
advances in treatment and by the way
this is why you know these days that
feel like months and weeks that feel
like years are good just the same
because we're learning very very fast
and even getting this disease now is
much better than getting it a week ago
let alone a month ago
in terms of your like the outcome
because we've learned along the way or
what yeah yeah yeah bout the
pathophysiology about the treatments I
mean they they've evolved remarkably in
terms of the ventilator what's clear is
you put somebody in a ventilator if you
have absolutely no choice if they just
you cannot oxygenate them without a
ventilator yep put them on a ventilator
and then try to get them off but if if
you've got you know even this much
latitude you don't put them on a
ventilator you give them oxygen and you
do simple things like reposition them
they're on their left side they're on
the right side if you can manage it
they're over on their stomachs and it
makes a huge difference in oxygenation
just repositioning so the protocol a
week prior had been plummeting oxygen
level intubate them protocol when I was
in the emergency room was do everything
possible to avoid intubating them give
them high flow to change their position
frequently and waited out for an hour to
see what's happening and I watched
patients get better in an hour
that would have been intubated and
shipped off to the ICU that week or
amazing and then similarly rapid
advances in the medical treatment almost
everybody that we admitted had a
coagulopathy in other words they were at
risk of blood clot formation and there's
a specific test called a d-dimer test
that you can do quite rapidly to see is
your coagulation system in overdrive
everybody's was so everybody got an
anticoagulant and a lot of the the
adverse outcomes in people who had been
admitted the month prior or related to
blood clot formation and you know we
didn't know that that was happening so
they weren't routinely treated for it
now they're treated preemptively for
that and a number of other medical
advances too and of course you know now
there's a lot there was interest in
hydroxychloroquine that interest has
sort of moved on to a drug called rum
Desa vir but the simple fact is you know
all around the world there is real-time
experimentation to figure out what works
you know one of the great problems we've
not talked about it yet
it's incredible how bad it is to conjoin
the greatest crisis
in public health and living memory with
a an utterly inept federal government
but you know and that combination is
truly dreadful and yet you know we
really have a massive boondoggle in
terms of you know the leadership of our
country right now it's been a huge
problem throughout this crisis and one
of the things I've been inclined to say
throughout is if only grown-ups were in
charge right if we really we had
enlightened compassionate leadership
that respected science and listened to
the right experts so you know we ought
to have and should long since have had
at the federal level a clearinghouse
that everybody could access with
promising innovations best practices and
they should know it should be
transparent there should be criteria to
be screened and filtered daily by an
army of you know three hundred people
trained in science and public
immediately none of this is rocket
science none of this is a trip to Mars
there's some effort and there's some
person time involved but in the absence
of grown-ups running the country there
are thankfully grown-ups running
hospitals and clinics and research labs
and there has been massive exchange of
ideas and little by little the best
practices are percolating to the top and
everybody's adopting them and then that
becomes the new standard and then
there's another round of experimentation
to see what is the best of that tier so
yeah everybody can take comfort in the
fact that the clinical management of
koba 19 is advancing very rapidly well
we could spend a lot of time
deconstructing the federal government's
approach or or lack thereof to this
pandemic my hope of course is that this
is a learning experience that will
inform the creation of institutions and
protocols that will help us manage these
sorts of situations in the future but
you met you mentioned that you're going
to be speaking to Homeland Security I'm
curious about your interface with the
administration have you had an
opportunity to communicate with
ouchy or his team or what is your
relationship to the administration and
you know are you in a position where
you're of counsel to what is happening
or what does that look like right now
it's interesting so you know you
mentioned before how I did Mike my piece
in The New York Times became something
of a lightning rod I I don't think
that's because of what I wrote in the
New York Times I think it's because I
wrote my op-ed Tom Friedman wrote his
and then President Trump we did let's
not let the Cure be worse than the
disease that was the title of my op-ed
in the New York Times right it was it
was an immediate response to having read
that piece of course and it dovetails
perfectly into you know his preferred
approach that's what it looked like yeah
governance by tweet and you know that I
mean nuanced policy responses to the
most complicated public health crisis
and living memory is not conducive to
governance by tweet but you know I think
what happened was people sort of blamed
me for the presidential tweet which I
didn't sanction you know I never favored
everybody back in the water never mind
riptides and the sharks you know I
talked about a data-driven risk
stratified pivot from horizontal to
vertical in tradition so it's been sort
of fraud because it I think if this were
a different administration I would have
actively campaigned to have access and
and you know I think they would have
welcomed it I you know it you don't have
to look very hard into my paper trail to
see where I stand with regard to this
administration so I don't think you know
they'd be very comfortable meeting with
me directly you know I think foul Chi
probably you know knows he has all the
expertise he needs his problem is his
boss so mostly it's been indirect
channels have had some communication
with with foul Chi's associates and
they've had some communication with
people associated with Joe Biden and
have spoken to several governors but
this opportunity to interact with a
bipartisan committee of the Sen
is probably the best opportunity to
influence the administration in a way
that actually means something because
you know there'll be several witnesses
we'll all get to make a statement for
five minutes then be subject to Q&A and
then all of that information will be
available and there'll be so much more
substance to that than you know trying
to influence the president who again you
know views this is just another
situation to either declare one extreme
or the other it's a hoax it's a war who
can we blame for it you know so I really
struggled with that I've had colleagues
ask me you know if you were asked to be
on the coronavirus task force would you
do it you know i don't know i don't i
don't trust the person in charge of the
information to do the right things with
it so I've been looking for ways to
influence the policy response my working
with people I felt would put information
to good use
I've been very impressed with Governor
Cuomo we've spoken and you know I think
he got caught up for a while in the race
to procure resources so you know that
there was a lot of focus on the nuances
of policy and then he disappeared for a
while I think it was all because he
wanted to make sure he had PPE for
everybody who needed it and ventilators
in hospital beds but I think you know
now he's sort of moving back and looking
at how do we start to open up New York
in a responsible way minimize total harm
so I you know I think I've had a real
influence there and I think there's real
opportunity because the governor's all
talk to one another they're looking for
best practices and even though you know
they're varying perspectives to some
extent partisan to some extent related
to character they are all looking
carefully at one another to see who
produces the best outcome
so my efforts are mostly focused there
and where does Michael osterholm fall
along this spectrum of influence and
opinion yeah so you know I consider Mike
certainly way above my pay grade when it
comes to pandemic response specifically
you know I think I said I know more
about the social determinants than he
does but I think mike is arguably you
know the single leading expert
on pandemic response in the country and
widely viewed as such so when I have
questions I ask him and one of the
questions I asked him just a couple days
ago is should I shut up should I stop
talking and he said no don't because you
know you you you absolutely do have the
big cuz I thought you know I'm getting
all this attention I thought it would
stop I thought I had 15 minutes and in
the spotlight and it would have gone
away a long time but it just keeps going
and going and should I just say you know
go talk to Mike he said no you know I
mean first of all it's really important
to be able to speak clearly it's really
important to take complicated things and
express them the way that that you know
the lay public can understand and you're
absolutely right there's more to this
story than just the virus or virology or
infection you know there there are all
these other things knowing you've got it
you've got to keep doing like my wife
was listening quietly in the back rooms
I just had a conversation with her sad
you know I need my life back I know the
world wants their lives back but I'm not
just living through you know this
surreal period but I'm living through
this surreal period drinking from a
firehose I've never been busier I'm
hearing family you know we're home
twiddling our thumbs you know do you
want to read poetry I'm say are you
kidding I have you know 15 hour work
days I'm happy if I can get a night's
sleep but Mike said no you got to keep
going and in terms of our points of view
very very highly confluent but with one
important exception mike says past
pandemics have fooled us and so he
natively is much more concerned about a
second wave than I have been so I you
know I've looked at the day then said
Wow
he almost everywhere we look with a we
do have decent testing for a population
about 20% of people exposed get infected
and about you know 98 to 99 percent of
those who get infected have a relatively
mild case and that pattern just plays
out again and again again all around the
world it looks to me like there's a lot
of native resistance the people who you
know who get this mostly become immune
and we're well on our way to hurt
immunity and and mike says not so fast
you know we were start
feel good about some of the past bad flu
years and they waned in one season then
came back in the fall that happened with
the famous pandemic of 1918 as well I'm
not convinced yet that were through this
I'm not convinced there won't be
subsequent waves and he cites data about
you know high rates of infection in one
country and low rates in a neighboring
country and no good reason to account
for it I'm tempted to think a lot of
that has to do with demographics you
know differences in age distribution and
and baseline health and testing so we
know there's a lot of infection in
countries that do a lot of testing we
think there's almost no infection in
countries that do no testing but that's
not because they don't have the disease
it's because they haven't ascertained
right but mike is more nervous about a
second wave and when somebody like Mike
talks about stuff like that I shut up
and listen and so you know he's made me
temper my views and think this is what
the data are saying this is what I think
I'm reasonably optimistic but I think we
have to stay really well prepared
because past pandemics have surprised us
in unpleasant ways so do we need a
supply of PPE could we need surge
capacity in our hospital system do we
need a surge supply of ventilators just
in case things get bad in the fall hell
yeah and whatever we do in terms of
policy we have to do it nimbly we have
to be prepared at every step of the way
for an empirical reality check this made
sense based on what we knew but we
didn't know enough to be sure and and
you know this is something I will also
tell the Senate committee and I've been
saying this day as well if anybody tells
you they're absolutely sure what's the
right thing to do in this situation run
like hell in the other direction because
we just don't have enough data to know
for sure what's around the next bend so
I've been very gratified when I can you
know I can get Mike's attention so
readily I've taken advantage of that
we've spoken multiple times exchanged
information if I have doubts about
something I shared with him they're
there others too and you know I'm really
surrounded by a group that knows a lot
but I don't pretend to be an expert in
all of this and I
happily learn from those who are and and
Mike's point of view is encouraging up
to a point but having you know been up
close and personal with prior pandemics
he says you know keep your powder dry
right what is your sense of the value of
contact tracking apps at this point
there's been a lot of discussion about
that leveraging technology to get better
data and balancing that against privacy
concerns yeah so I've never really
focused preferentially on that I you
know I think I would be happy to know
right now what is the estimated
prevalence of infection in the United
States what is the estimated prevalence
of immunity and what I've advocated is
to build a data pair of it so I'd like
you know I'd like to be able to
extrapolate from a representative random
sample total number infected total
number immune out of that group how many
had any symptoms at all out of that
group how many sought medical attention
at all out of that group how many got
hospitalized out of that group how many
needed the ICU would have that group how
many died and then how does all of that
relate to a range of age BMI health
status and that would be almost
everything I need to know and if that
told you okay the disease is bad and
that we really need to interrupt spread
pretty much anytime someone gets
infected contact tracing becomes crucial
if that pyramid tells us you know again
everything we thought we knew from other
countries is true 98 to 99 percent of
all cases are mild and if you talk about
people under 50 free of major chronic
disease 99.999 percent of cases are mild
is it really worth the effort to put
privacy at risk to do contact tracing in
that group I'd say what we really want
to do is make sure we carefully shield
the most vulnerable from exposure and if
we're going to do contact tracing let's
focus that to that population as well to
make
essentially we're identifying have you
had an exposure do we need to do pulse
oximetry because you know if you are 72
years old and we think you've been
exposed we want to detect the slightest
initial decline in your oxygenation
level so we can pounce on it we don't
want we don't want to wait until you
know you've got high fever or wracked
with chills and your oxygen is dropping
below 90 because you know we've missed
the opportunity to intervene early so I
I would say selective my impression is
with you know with the right data
pyramid to guide us contact tracing
could be directed to protecting the
highly vulnerable but you know I don't
think we need to care what the level of
exchange is among college students
wanting to incur is almost
overwhelmingly they're gonna have a mild
or asymptomatic bout of this you know
why do why do we need to know everybody
they've associated with it's a huge
amount of data to process to very little
good and you know I would say the effort
that we invest in every aspect of
interdiction here should be guided by
the likelihood of it saving lives
preventing bad outcomes and I would
channel it accordingly
so I see some value in it but I would
tend to approach it selectively where is
your head in terms of optimism versus
pessimism in terms of you know how we're
approaching this as a society like
weight forecasting weeks or perhaps
several months into the future what do
you think is most is is our most likely
approach to this and and where are we
going to see ourselves and find
ourselves come July August September
again I think if only because we have
these opposing forces of lock it all
down until there's a vaccine everybody
back out to the world right away you
know I think it almost the inevitable
result of those tensions is okay middle
path now just just so happens at the
middle path I think is a good idea
anyway in terms of minimizing total harm
so I think you know we could have gotten
there because of science and sense we
may get there because you know
the only way out of an impasse that's so
polarized but I think we're headed
toward that where we phase back to the
world I think inevitably it will be
somewhat data-driven because we have
data and governors are looking at the
data they have I think it will be
somewhat experimental because we have
Republican governors and Democratic
governors and they're inclined to do
things differently so Georgia I think
fungals by opening everything up too
soon I think there may be states that
say lockdown too long but you know to
some extent I think the governor's will
be looking for okay who passes the
Goldilocks test you're to lock down your
to opened up looks like you're having
the best experience I'll have I'll have
what she's having right I think there'll
be some of that I hope that we do rally
to a nationally representative random
sample again it's not a huge job would
make a huge difference so you know I
think maybe this testimony to the Senate
will influence that I think that could
happen I think it should happen and then
you know I think we will start to see
things open in waves and it's a little
bit like put your toe in the water put
your foot in the water put your leg in
the water and you know let's see what
happens so I think I think at this point
we have propagated enough anxiety about
this that even when things open up
they're going to be a lot of people who
are reticent about letting their
families go out to the world I do think
there's an opportunity to supplant or
supplement rather policy responses with
informed and empowered individual
decision making so I think the
deployment of tools that help you can
you know quantify your own risk
for a severe outcome I think those would
be timely I think there's a real
opportunity for what you and I were
doing before all this where we tell
people look you know the stuff that that
was placing your health in peril before
in slow motion is now an acute threat do
something about it you know I'd like to
see a federally mediated let's get
healthy now campaign but I think a lot
of individuals are going to be saying I
really like to do something about you
know my hypertension my diabetes my
weight where can I get help I think that
maybe
part of this there may really be an aha
moment about health in America uh you
know I and then the question becomes
what happens with my parents for example
you know when do we give them the all
clear so you know my inclination would
be we we look at viral transmission we
continue to track it we try to get
better data about the the prevalence of
antibodies and when it seems that we
have a high level of immunity among at
least whatever portion the population
tends to get this thing and near-zero
transmission of the virus they get to
come back out to the world nug their
grandchildren Mike Oscar Holmes point of
view and and the point of view of others
who are warning we may see waves of this
is is a precautionary tale bill that
says you know let's let's be really
careful about the potential need for
sheltering vulnerable populations again
at a later date if in fact we got a low
and then another surge again that may be
true I cannot dismiss points of view
from people as well-informed as my but
it I can't I can't use the the notion of
waves to account for what's happening on
Navy ships I can't use the notion of
waves to account for what happened on
the diamond princess why is it that on
an uncontained ship only twenty percent
of people got infected they were all
exposed to one degree or another but you
know a that attend people on the ship
didn't get the bug at least in in terms
of what our testing tells us and most of
those who did get infected got over it
and and are now immune so far as we know
to me that's very encouraging so I'm you
know I look at South Korea I look at
Iceland I look at Germany I look at
Sweden I look at the diamond princess I
look at the Navy vessels and I say you
know honestly I'm pretty optimistic I
think I think a lot of the population
isn't really resistant just at this
thing even if they're exposed I think
most people who get it if you know
they're not very elderly or not
seriously ill or both recover from it we
are getting better treating it I think
we do need to shelter the vulnerable
both because it's not safe for them to
and because that's the best way to avoid
overwhelming medical system but I think
we can stop doing that when the rest of
us have already been out in the world
tested the waters for them and said
viral transmissions near zero and then
we just stay lay out light on our feet
so if it starts to recur
we have adaptive policies but I think we
get to something approximating life as
we knew it before within the next couple
of months that's encouraging
it does appear to be a very strange and
perhaps unique disease in the manner in
which it afflicts people you know as you
mentioned there are at-risk groups of
course but we're all hearing the stories
of the robust 30 year old you know
jiu-jitsu artists or you know athlete
who suddenly contracts this and and dies
and I would I would suspect those are
outlier cases but they're also alarming
in that it doesn't appear to have a
rhyme or reason in who it in the manner
in which it impacts people in this
disparate way and I think that creates a
lot of fear and confusion among people
that makes it more difficult to wrap
your head around like what the best
course of action is for yourself right
like I feel like you know I'm 53 but I'm
pretty healthy I don't spend a lot of
time thinking about what it would be
like to to become that ill or to
contract this disease but in the back of
my mind I'm aware of those those stories
and it weighs on me and I think about
that when I venture out into the world
and I Chuck's to pose that against you
know I think that that you know we've
all been locked down for a period of
time and I don't know what the vibe is
in Connecticut in New York at the moment
but I can tell you in California there's
the there's a growing restlessness I
think human beings are only wired to be
able to adhere to this kind of thing for
for so long before they just start
bursting at the seams and and they're
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna I'm gonna go out
into the world and roll the dice I'll be
safe but you know I'm just not going to
stay at home any longer and I'm seeing
that you know
now and and so there's a like kind of a
leakage or our spillover effect that
irrespective of what the government is
telling us we should or shouldn't do or
can or can't do people are still gonna
do what they're gonna do exactly it's
all the more reason why we are going to
move into a next phase of this soon if
only because human nature drives us
there but back to the other point I
totally agree rich and and you know
again this issue of you know it kills
young healthy people it kills young
health professionals it does but you do
not make it through week one of
Epidemiology 101 without learning to ask
always and every time what is the
denominator so I had a beloved colleague
a really a dear friend it's hard for me
to tell the story even these several
years later and not choked up but after
Ollie we worked together clinically for
15 years
first naturopathic physician ever on the
faculty at Yale died at 42 of esophageal
cancer
I have no goddamn idea why he never
smoked a top Tamale practiced meditation
daily exercise routinely beautiful wife
lovely children gentle kind loving
thoughtful purposeful I mean just
beautiful beautiful human being I you
know it makes me angry
what unkind fate and then just recently
I have a friend where where I ride my
horse she's in her forties pancreatic
cancer no risk factors no reason if we
told every one of those stories with the
commitment we have to telling every
coalbed story you know what's going on
yeah pancreatic cancer esophageal cancer
and there enough of them out there's a
critical mass of these stories they
could be in the news every day and we
would wind up thinking my god I think
I'm 57 year 42 I was healthy I didn't
think I had to be afraid for my life
every day but every day there's another
story of a person my age or younger my
health or better getting some dreadful
disease we thought only happened to
people with risk factors what's going on
oh my god the sky is falling it's human
nature to want to know why and in
medicine one of the things you have to
reconcile yourself to over the years is
you often have
ocean of Y and sometimes I have a clue
and when enough people get coded if
millions and millions again zero
prevalence suggest four million people
in New York State alone have had this
when millions of people get something
some of them are going to have a really
bad bizarre outcome you can't account
for based on their health or their agent
and then of course you know with the the
health care professionals they're still
quite rare because you know most of the
frontline people have been exposed
probably who had this and gotten over it
so it's it's probably a very tiny
fraction of the the health professional
cohort that has a severe case but it may
have something to do a dose you know
another thing you don't you don't make
it through your mph degree without
learning is that infectious disease is
host agent environment the host is you
and me the agent in this case is
Tsarskoe v2 and the environment is you
know very different if you were you know
in a room where somebody with COBIT had
been a couple hours ago you were exposed
to some small number of viral particles
you got a little bit sick in your immune
system took care of it versus you were
doing bronchoscopy in the ICU and we're
exposed to a massive dose of viral
particles that overwhelm your defenses
and there's an easy way for people to
think of this it's a pretty good analogy
you know you have a compound you're
defending your perimeter and your
defense is your immune system and if you
if there's an ambush by a relatively
small number of the enemy you can repel
them if that same enemy amounts of force
that is a hundred times bigger than your
defense force you get overwhelmed and
really bad things happen viral
infections like that so the dose of
exposure is basically the size of that
ambush it makes a huge difference in
whether your immune system gets the
upper hand early or whether it's
completely overwhelmed I think that
accounts for some of the health
professionals but but again some of this
is you're just right and it's scary some
of this is yeah but it's because we're
telling COBIT stories in every news
cycle and comparably bad things for
comparably bizarre reasons are happening
to young people around the country every
day
and we're not telling those stories so
it looks like COBIT is the one and only
risk and oh dear God sky is falling it's
a distortion it really is the risk is
small well you've been incredibly
generous with your time and I want to be
mindful of that and release you to your
life in a minute but before we wrap this
up I think it would be good to to end it
with some thoughts on on you know what
we can do personally you we spoke
earlier a little bit about immunity
obviously we want to maximize and boost
our our bodies a you know immune
response we want our immune system to be
functioning at its peak there are
certain things that we can do lifestyle
practices and dietary protocols that can
enhance that and I think this is a
subject matter that we could talk about
for hours but is yeah I want to keep it
brief but it's it's a you know it's kind
of an underrepresented conversation in
this dialogue around coronavirus what we
can do personally to make sure that
we're as healthy as possible so should
we come into contact with the virus
we're in the best position to be able to
confront it and overcome it absolutely I
think it's a huge issue and and
interestingly it's another one that we
polarized so you've got people sort of
peddling nutrient supplements
willy-nilly and then you've got articles
in The New York Times and elsewhere
telling people diet nutrition nutrients
don't make any difference and and both
of those are silly you know it's not as
if you're going to take some number of
supplements and it's going to make you
bulletproof but the idea that diet makes
no difference to immunity is absurd
every day your body is replacing white
blood cells and the construction
material comes from your nutrition and
so whether or not those cell membranes
are optimized whether or not you're able
to replenish the productive capacity of
your bone marrow absolutely dependent on
every aspect of diet it's not just one
nutrient yes zinc is important vitamin D
is important all of that but it's the
full array of amino acids is the full
array of fatty acids a balanced diet you
is the source of construction material
for the replenishable portion of your
immunity think about antibodies we
talked about antibodies well those are
proteins you have to build them you need
you know an optimal diet to build
optimal materials and then there's
antioxidants that the key role of
antioxidants is to defend your healthy
cells your immune system is like an army
it's engaged in chemical warfare there
is the risk of collateral damage and
frankly one of the reasons people get so
sick with kovat is this cytokine storm
which is activation of the immune system
to fight the virus doing damage to your
healthy tissues balancing your immune
response so it's not excessive but it's
also adequate it has a lot to do with
balance nutrition protecting your
healthy cells has a lot to do with
balance nutrition so enormous ly
important and it's immediately
actionable you know we've done studies
over the years when I was directing the
prevention center at Yale looking at
vascular function and and you know key
measures of homeostasis and health that
change in response to a single meal so
people should not think you know I know
diet and lifestyle important but they
can't help me in time they can help you
in time you can make a difference today
you can make a real big difference in
the span of some days and you can make
an enormous difference you can pretty
much do a 180 in a span of weeks and
that's fast enough so you know we're
trying to do everything we can to help
with this again collaborating with
colleagues on a personal risk calculator
as you know rich I run a company now
diet ID where we can assess diet pattern
diet quality nutrient intake level and
we're making that freely available
direct-to-consumer we're a b2b business
but we're actually making this available
to people so they can see whether or not
their diet is a risk factor for Kovan
and do something about it immediately
and we help coach them to a more optimal
diet so you can learn more about that at
diet I decom but the big picture here is
that you know stuff about diet lifestyle
health that maybe didn't grab your
attention before because again it didn't
trigger a fight-or-flight response
suddenly it does suddenly you know
you're not that yeah yeah you know I
I know I'm at risk for heart disease or
diabetes but I could fix that tomorrow
and tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
never comes but you're literally worried
about COBIT infection tomorrow and all
of a sudden years that help well good
news you really can do something about
it so physical activity really important
enough sleep really important obviously
all the stuff about personal hygiene
managing stress all those key elements
of lifestyle is medicine that were
important for if you smoke there's never
been a better time to quit but there's
also never been a better time to improve
your diet and there are some nutrients
that probably are a good idea vitamin D
is one zinc is another vitamin C maybe a
third maybe you'll make three to balance
immune system response but one of the
best defenses against a bad outcome here
would be to optimize your diet mmm I
think people know what that looks like
but on the off chance they don't you
want to be eating lots of vegetables
fruits whole grains beans lentils nuts
and seeds plain water when thirsty you
know that the more you're eating whole
plant foods the better in terms of all
of these different elements and and you
know if we took the hours you just
mentioned we really could talk through
all the mechanistic pathways how does
that translate into antibody production
how does that translate into lymphocyte
production activity and neutrophil
production act it you know there's a
there there this is not whiff T this is
not you know trying to make the case
that that is important you've got whole
textbooks on the the linkages between
dietary intake endocrine balance immune
system function it's fundamentally
important it can alter your risk in
hours and certainly days and profoundly
in weeks
so I would say you know there's never
been a better time don't let another day
go by where you don't at least try to
leverage the power diet to protect you
against this bug mmm yeah that's
fantastic advice well thank you David I
hope to continue that aspect of the
conversation at a future date and and do
a podcast the way that we originally
conceptualized it where we can go deep
on diet and lifestyle for people that
listening you did a great job on
Danielle Blair does podcast a while back
where you kind of laid out your whole
perspective on nutrition and that's
certainly valuable if people are
watching or listening I could point you
to that but hopefully I'll have an
opportunity to sit down and meet you in
person and and we could talk more I hope
you'll come back on the show I look
forward to that rich thanks you thanks
very much and thank you keep being a
voice out there I don't I don't envy
your political hot potato status at the
moment a voice of reason is much
appreciated in this moment of calamity
and I appreciate the work that you do
I'm a proud supporter of True Health
Initiative which hopefully we can talk
about more later and you know I've I've
been an avid fan and follower of the
work that you've been doing for a long
time and I just wish you well and and I
want you to keep doing what you're doing
so stay healthy
alright that's the plan thank you so
much reeling spend the rest of the day
packing up this microphone that you said
back in the box we tried to make it easy
I think it worked out fine how do you
feel yeah this is my first I've done a
couple remote podcast but this is the
first time I've tried to do it on video
and I think it went pretty good yeah you
made me people want to learn more about
you and your work what's the best place
to point them towards my website links
to diet ID and true health initiatives
is probably the easiest place for
one-stop shopping David Katz MD comm
right and I'll put links up in the show
notes you also write quite frequently on
LinkedIn where you put some longer
thought pieces there so I'll direct ya
the website things do that too
yeah thank you alright and listen I
really appreciate what you do so thank
you so much thank you
alright well until next time David
thanks so much take care see you see all
right yes
[Music]